all right thanks everyone for joining us
today for the our CPP parallel webinar
our CPP parallel being quite the tongue
twister to say so please forgive me if I
messed that up a couple times during
this presentation all right hopefully
you are now seeing my screen and some
slides on our CPP parallel let's dive
right in alright so a brief introduction
about why do you why would you be
interested or why would you care in our
CPP parallel parallel and concurrent
programming is a reality of modern
software development and is necessary
when developing high-performance
scientific software so I've got here a
quote from herb Sutter who is kind of a
C++ / high performance computing guru
over at Microsoft and he wrote in this
article free lunch is over the
performance lunch isn't free anymore if
you want your application to benefit
from continued exponential Throop
advances and new processors it will need
to be a well written concurrent usually
multi-threaded application and now this
is a quote that comes from an essay
written in 2004 that's like 12 years ago
now and well pressed processors and
compilers continue to improve processor
clock speed has hit a brick wall
processors basically haven't gotten much
faster at all in the past 10 years so
we've had to look to other avenues for
improving the performance of computer
processors so you might be familiar with
some of the packages for parallel
computation with our for example the
parallel package which I believe became
part of our with 2.15 around that era of
our and so our provides the number of
packages that make it possible to run
our code in parallel so you might know
about MC apply cluster apply power
applied that those family of functions
and what these functions do is they
allow you to take our code
and run it in separate our processes
these are processes running in parallel
and then later collect the results from
those processes back into a parent our
process see if you have a cluster with a
number of nodes you might imagine
sending a number of jobs to these
separate nodes and each node here would
be running this our code computer is alt
and then send that back to the parent
node or parent process and there is a
cran task view that enumerates the
number of our packages that help support
different forms of parallel computing
with our now what are CPP parallel does
is a bit different from the r family of
parallel packages the goal in our CPP
parallel is not to execute our code in
parallel but to allow our to call
lower-level C or C++ code that is
executed in parallel so if you whether
you're on you know so you've got a
laptop with two or four cores or a
desktop with four cores or you have some
supercomputer that has say 32 64 cores
and a ton of memory the goal of our CPP
parallels but those cores to their best
use for whatever algorithms are trying
to implement now for those of you who
haven't done much of this kind of
lower-level on parallel or concurrent
programming unfortunately it's quite
hard and this is a silly quote from a
fellow named Ned bachelor some people
when confronted with a problem think I
know I'll use threads now they have true
problems
the idea being here you have if you ever
have two threads or multiple threads
multiple processes trying to write to
standard output you can get this weird
interleaving of output where the stuff
you get back is just garbage totally
garbled and that's kind of a common
theme in parallel computing or
concurrent programming the hardest part
is managing shared resources in this
case the shared resource being the
output stream that people are trying to
write to or threads are trying to
and when you have multiple threads
trying to write to standard output
without appropriate locking or threads
taking ownership say okay it's my turn
to write and then releasing it and let
other people's write then you get these
kinds of problems so the goal of our
superior of all is to make it easier
right safe correct and performing
multi-threaded code using C++ and our
CPP and use that within an R accession
and and more than that it's to make sure
that you the user don't have to worry
about this issues with contention over
shared resources for example if you have
an R object that you want to read or use
for multiple processes we want to give
you some tools that make it easy to
safely and performant lis use that on
all of your cores on your machine
alright so the way that RSPB parallel
does what it does is that it bundles two
C++ libraries that do most of the grunt
work for parallel computation so the
first one Intel TBB is a C++ library for
task parallelism with a wide variety of
parallel algorithms and data structures
and we've got this working on all of the
major platforms Windows OS X Linux and
even Solaris and so in the most common
case you're gonna be using Intel TBB
threading building blocks and this is
the library that behind the scenes of
our CPP parallel is going to make sure
that when you designate a job that you
want to run in parallel it's going to do
all the work of spawning different
threads and just making sure that your
work runs in parallel and it runs fast
now we also bundle taani thread which is
a very small C++ library for the
portable use of operating system threads
but nowadays because until TBB is
supported on all the platforms that are
commonly used by our users in general
you're going to be using Intel TBB of
course as a user of RSP
parallel you don't need to dive into the
internals of TVB because we present a
nice interface that I'll be showing soon
well it's good to know you know who's
doing the heavy lifting behind the
scenes so our CP parallel tries to solve
I guess it tries to provide interfaces
for two main functions for two common
types of work that you might want to do
in parallel the first function we
provide is a function called parallel
for the idea is that this will convert
the work of a standard serial for loop
into a parallel one and the second one
is parallel reduce which provides a way
to compute and aggregate multiple values
in parallel so these are functions
provided by our CP V parallel and behind
the scenes they're going to delegate the
work to the TVB Intel threading building
blocks library so the way that these
functions work is effectively that they
accept this thing that I'm going to call
a worker object and this worker is going
to know how to do work on a particular
slice of data and I'll get into examples
very soon all right so as a brief
outline of how these functions work just
to set the stage each of these functions
accept a range of data to operate on and
a worker that understands how to do work
on slices of that data for example the
parallel for function and I should just
reiterate that this is a C++ function
not an our function so hopefully you
have a bit of familiar with C or C++ but
this is just the signature of a function
called parallel for next it's accepting
a begin and an end index here the size T
parameter being like an index parameter
and work her being the worker object I
briefly discussed before so you're going
to give this parallel four algorithm a
range to operate on and a worker
designation that knows how to do work
within that range
so as a user of our CP parallel you can
implement your own worker by sub
classing this are superior parallel
worker class and implementing the
routines routines that do work on a
slice of data and so after you write the
code that does the work and you call
parallel for behind-the-scenes TVB is
going to go ahead and generate multiple
workers divide them across your data and
make sure that it's gonna be responsible
for making sure this worker runs in
parallel or more accurately that
multiple workers are generated to
operate on slices of the data all right
so let's start with a little example of
how you might use a parallel worker just
to see how you would call it before we
think about how we would implement a
worker all right so first we're just
going to look at this is a little stub
of C++ code where we're trying to
compute the log of a vector in parallel
so if you've never seen C++ or RSVP
before what we have here is just a stub
for a worker class and I promise you
you'll see an implementation for this
soon what is just something we're
calling the log worker and it inherits
from the RCPD parallel worker class so
this is our way of saying okay this is
the log worker this is the thing that's
going to do work for computing the log
on some range of data and here this our
CPP x4 - your boot I'll be showing you
more later but it's basically over there
saying please make this available to the
arsh our session later we've got a
function that takes an R CPP numeric
vector think of it like a regular
numeric vector in R and so wrapper to
the same object we've got our parallel
law accepting some other numeric vector
as input so what we're going to do to
compute our log on this numeric vector
now if you're working in the are world
everything is nicely vectorized for you
but in the C or C++ worlds you're going
to have to
normally what you would have to do is
write a for loop to iterate over that so
you might have expected something like
for I equals 0 I equals then I plus plus
compute the log of this element and set
it somewhere well for the RCPD parallel
case what we're going to do is
pre-allocate our output vector have it
be the same size as our input vector and
here the no 1 it is just a helper that
says just give me a chunk of memory I'm
gonna fill it later don't worry about 0
initializing it or anything like that
we're going to construct our log worker
here it's going to take our input vector
and it's going to know how to fill the
output vector and then we call the
parallel for function on the range of
that vector with that worker so that
worker is going to know how to fill that
output vector ok so let's see how we
might implement that log worker so this
is a this is actually the whole
implementation of how you might
implement the log worker here so first
we've got some this is a little header
that says I'll show you in the IDE too
soon that says oh this code snippet
depends on the heart's to be parallel we
bring in the header as we're using our
CPP parallel and our CPP here I'm I'm
just defining a small func tour it looks
kind of weird but just if you're not
familiar with this notation just imagine
that log here is like a function log is
a function a thing that can compute the
log and our log worker is going to
accept instances of that to compute the
log
all right so now let's look at our log
worker once just to go back for a second
here we're going to fill in the blanks
in here so we've got some members input
and output these are just going to be
references to the R vectors the input
vector and output vector our constructor
takes those and fills those and the
reason why we use our vector here is
just as am parallel safe version of the
regular our
factor our speech parallel tries to give
you these them safe wrappers to our
objects that you know can be used safely
in parallel because if you try to use
arbitrary elements of the our API you
can rub into trouble if you're using
those in the parallel work in general
the code that you put in an RCP be
parallel worker should not touch the our
API directly you should stick with the
C++ functions or other C++ libraries
available in language alright so we've
got our constructor this is how our log
workers made it just stories references
to the input and output and here is
where we define our work this is the
implementation for a worker to do work
on some slice of data so if you haven't
seen this thing before it's basically a
way of saying okay I want this class to
behave kind of like a function I want
this objects of this class to be
callable so when you call this worker
this is the function that would get
called and so this operator it doesn't
return anything so whatever it's doing
it's doing as a side-effect and the
things that it takes in are indices
being the begin and end like the slice
of data that the worker should work on
and here I'm using a STL algorithms did
transform that takes input iterators and
an output editor and a function to apply
as it goes through so each worker is
going to do a bunch of work in serial
but behind the scenes parallel for is
generating a whole bunch of these
workers that will do this work across
different slices of data and they'll do
those work in parallel so as a quick
micro benchmark that I did um beforehand
if you want to compare this to just
computing the log and R and using our
parallel log function in our spirit
parallel if we took a little micro
benchmark you see that our parallel
solution and this is on not
Pro having four processors we might
expect in the best case we get four four
times performance of course in practice
you won't see a.m. you'll see a bit of
drop-off as you scale parallel
algorithms to the number of cores you
have but it should still be a
significant benefit but what we see here
is that our parallel log is roughly
three times faster than ours love so
that's a nice one just to dive into the
details I don't want to go too deep here
yet because we've got documentation
online I just want to focus on the
high-level stuff but our CPU parallel
uses TBB in almost all scenarios and
that comes with highly optimized
execution scheduler and it does
intelligent optimization around the
grain size which affects locality of
reference and therefore cache hit rates
if you're familiar with modern
architectures of processors you know
that memory is now hierarchical you've
got l1 caches l2 caches l3 caches and
the goal is to make sure that you fill
the l1 cache and use all the data in
there if not you fill the l2 cache and
use all the data in there if you're
missing those caches if you have to go
back to main memory to get data and fill
back the cache you're gonna have cache
misses which are bad for performance so
TVB roughly speaking does its best to
make sure that you don't have cache
misses and finally it also helps with
work-stealing it tries to detect if
there's idle threads and say hey wake up
I've got some work for you to do alright
this is can all be tuned in RCP parallel
although I might not get to it in this
webinar all the details will be
available on the website alright and so
with that we've seen a bunch of nice
static stuff but now let's see this
interactive in the IDE excuse me so so
here I am in the our Studio IDE before I
start get started on the arts to be
parallel functions I was showing I just
want to iterate that the slides that
you're seeing today
those were built with our markdown and
so you've got this very nice offering
format for slides and you know if you
need to do a presentation yourself like
for a little internal company meeting or
even something bigger this can be a very
very nice way to put something like that
together so that's not what this webinar
is about so let's jump into our log
implementation so here I've combined the
bits of the log implementation that we
discussed in the slides I just want to
show you that I've got them all together
in one file here we've got our log
flunked or that returns the log got our
log worker has we discussed and we've
got our exported function that are we'll
see the parallel log function so now
when you're working on C++ files in the
IDE one thing that's very nice and
powered by the RSPB package is you can
actually take this file you can source
it when you save and what that'll do is
it'll go it'll compile the C++ file that
you're working on it'll link it it'll
load it into your accession and if
you've got a little block of our code
and like I do here at the bottom it'll
just go ahead and run that for you so
let's do that I'm gonna hit command s to
save let's see this source EBP at the
bottom thing that's about to source the
file wait a little bit as the compiler
runs all right sourced now notice that
it goes through and runs all this code
here I'm just sharing a 10-million out
America rector convinced myself that
we're computing the same thing with ours
log and the RC parallel log and then
we'll use micro benchmark to compute a
benchmark and we get roughly the same
results as we saw before so if you are
whether you're a newcomer to C++ and are
CBP or you're kind of a veteran there's
usually this kind of painful build
iteration in C++ in that you have to
compile your C+ files you have to link
and then you maybe have a test harness
or something you run but it's really
nice in the IDE that you can just take
your C++ file and source it and run it
directly in the IDE like it couldn't be
simpler alright so I showed a brief
example of the parallel for let's jump
over to the parallel reduce and for this
example I'll compute the inner product
so if you recall the inner product of
two vectors is effectively what you get
if you multiply each element in those
two vectors element wise and then sum
those products up so actually let's yeah
so here I've got my little R
implementation of how do I do that it's
like nice and small and succeeding
that's not going to be running in
parallel let's see how we might do that
in parallel with ours to be parallel all
right so first we're going to define a
little function product just so we have
something that we can pass to our inner
product worker and so product is a
function that takes two doubles and
returns our product nice and simple and
here we're going to have our inner
product worker and that's going to once
again inherit from our SP parallel
worker up here I've got our private
numbers LHS I say for left hand side RHS
for right hand side so these are going
to be our our vector inputs and then
output because we're computing a scalar
value we just want to compute a double
output value so the first thing that we
have is our regular constructor takes a
numeric factor on the left hand side a
numeric factor on the right hand side
and it fills these values we'll come
back to this constructor in a bit but
it'll be important when we understand
how the reduce stage of this operation
happens but let's look at the deed call
operator for this class and so each word
we're given a range it's going to try
and fill this output value and the C++
standard library it actually comes with
a algorithm for computing the inner
product so we can call that directly
over the range that we've been provided
so because these are um stood size T
they're numeric indexes we want to and
we want to pass iterators to inner
product what we're going to do here is
call LHS begin which is the very start
of the left-hand side vector and then
nudge that iterator forward to the
actual beginning of the range we want to
work on then similar here we want to
give it the end of the range to work on
and here is the right-hand side range
for when it computes the products have
elements and 0.0 here is just starting
value all right so now each worker is
going to be filling its own output value
so this value remember when we call
parallel reduce multiple workers are
going to be generated and they're all
going to be filling their own output
value so depending on how many workers
get generated there might be four or
eight there's me for eight of these
values so what we need to know is how
can we join these values together at the
end so you've got these kind of many
inner products on different ranges of
the data at different slices of the data
and we want to join those together
and we do that by implementing this join
function down here and it's kind of it's
relatively simple what you have here is
a function called join that accepts some
other worker the idea is that this
worker is going to provide the result of
its work to the active worker and to do
that all we have to do is add the output
that's been computed by the other worker
right to this own output here
all right and now knowing that we have
this join here this constructor that we
have here it's kind of just you can
almost think of it as boilerplate it's
just the magic constructor that's used
so it so that our CV parallel knows how
to split up workers in the parallel
reduce scenario and what we have in here
is it's kind of like a copy constructor
here we initialize the left-hand side
with the contents of the left hands the
other inner product workers left-hand
side same with the right-hand side and
the output alright so like we did before
I'm gonna take this I'm gonna set source
on save and hit command s well first
I'll clear the console with ctrl L and
I'll command asked to source it we've
got some R code at the bottom that's
going to run in a similar way and
compute the inner product in parallel
alright so once again we can convince
ourselves that yes we are computing the
correct value and if we run a little
micro benchmark we'll actually see oh my
gosh we're almost ten times faster than
what R is doing here and so I'm on a
laptop with only four cores so there
must be something else going on here and
actually what's happening in R you can
imagine that when you compute LHS times
RHS what you have is another a numeric
vector of the same length of the LHS and
RHS vectors so we're computing a whole
new vector and then you're finally
reducing or collapsing that by calling
some but in our parallel worker case
because we're just filling one single
output on each worker directly we're not
generating a whole new vector of the
same sizes or inputs we get a bit of
memory savings in addition to the
parallel of processing improvements so
there are some very nice gains to be
realized with our three parallel even on
your own commodity hardware but you can
imagine that it will scale and it does
scale in fact on
drue machines or supercomputers
computers with many processors all right
so I've shown you how to use these
functions standalone but what you might
want to know is okay I'm I'm excited
about arts to be parallel I want to
start you know I'm maybe a novice or I'm
experienced at this but I want to put
something together I want to share it
with other people how can I do that
and so in general when it comes to
sharing our code or things that should
be used in our session you should think
our package so if you have some
experience with our packages that'll be
helpful here if not we'll go through a
little demo of how you might build an R
package that uses ours to be parallel
behind-the-scenes and so I've got this
folder here R to be a parallel example
and it's gonna be a little R package
that I've pre-populated and we'll just
open that up and run through some of the
things that we did to make an r package
in our package so I'll switch to that
project here a parallel example doesn't
to save our workspace let me go back to
full screen all right let me clean up
some of these alright so now we are in
this little RC parallel example package
so you might be familiar with some of
these elements on the right-hand side of
your vanilla R package you've got the
description file you've got an our
folder that's full of some our files in
this case you have this thing called our
CV exports and we have our source folder
okay so this is kind of the general
layout of an r package I don't have time
to go through all of the details but I
assure you that there will be other
webinars and other materials online that
you can use to become more familiar if I
cross over a few things here so first I
just want to I've got a pre working
package here I'm just going to build it
what we have here is the
pilot runs to compile the package and
build it we built it we restart the our
session we love it and we've got our our
three parallel example package right
just to show that it's working we've got
that package loaded I just want to show
that we've got this our spiral example
oops
example and we've got these two
functions here that are in the package
ready to do some work for us okay so now
how how did we make that happen so in an
our package when you have compiled code
or C or C++ code you always put it in
the source folder in in our source
folder I have pretty much the same log
and inner product files that we've seen
before let's take a quick look at the
log file all this stuff up here it's
exactly as we saw before here this is
something a little different this if
you're familiar with our oxygen which is
a way of documenting functions and
classes in our files you can actually do
the same thing in C++ files and if
you're using dev tools to document it'll
parse those our oxygen comment these C++
our oxygen comments and promote them to
the exported our wrappers so what we
have here is effectively just the
documentation for this parallel log it's
a simple function computers the natural
log of a numeric vector takes a numeric
vector is in numeric vector as input and
this export declaration here says the
our wrapper that we generate we should
export it know this this is a little bit
confusing in that we have to export
statements but here this one is saying
for the generated our function make that
exported ie when someone loads this
package I want the R wrapper function to
be visible to them and this one is
saying well this function that we've got
here we want to make the C++ interface
available to the R package so this is a
little bit lower level and this is a way
of saying the parallel log function
should be generated the r wrapper
should be generated but this is saying
that that the generated our wrapper
function should be exported let me just
jump to show you that's true so this R
seems to be exports our file which is
auto-generated for us based on the
contents of this file what we see here
is in our parallel log it's the exact
same our oxygen documentation that we
discussed before in this little wrapper
function using dot call is the way of
saying I want to call some compiled code
with a function of this name in this
package so all you need to know is that
this stuff is done behind the scenes for
you and all you need to worry about is
writing your own C++ files with these
annotations that tell the RCPD package
in our studio how to build the wrapper
functions so given that what we have in
here is exactly the same as what we had
before for our inner product same thing
exact same thing that we looked at
before the only difference is we've
added a little bit of documentation so
that the our wrapper functions that are
generated have documentation and
actually we won't we just convince
ourselves that these things do have
documentation let's go look at the docs
and there they are parallel log
displayed nicely in the our our studio
help in alright so there's a number of
kind of fiddly prerequisites to our
packages using RSP parallel and you have
to make sure to follow each of them
otherwise unfortunately you can bump
into strange errors and one of them is
how you construct your namespace file so
this namespace file it tells our well
how to construct the namespace of your
package and that includes what function
should be exported or what functions or
object should be imported from other
packages so the first thing we'll do
here is i know i talked about dr oxford
in comments before but to keep things
super simple on our namespace
we're actually doing is using this
export pattern to say everything that
doesn't start with a dot I want that
made available to use this of our
package so this is the declaration that
says the parallel and a product in
parallel log our wrapper function should
be made available to users of the
package now this one is a little scary
and I actually bumped into this while
preparing the webinar for the arts of
your parallel talk so if anything it's
pretty important to follow directions
otherwise unfortunately you will see
some strange things and if you try to
build your package and let me see if I
can actually just remove using convince
you that strange things go wrong you
clean and rebuild this see all this
compiler output build it in something
bizarre went wrong and so you see this
here this symbol not found test it's
like a mangled name it's a mangled name
of the function that it's trying to call
us saying oh that thing doesn't exist
and that's basically because when when
the package is being built and loaded
the RCPD parallel package isn't loaded
alongside it so that the routines in the
RSPB parallel package which our example
packages using are not available so our
loads are packaged and says hey that
where's this symbol and looking for
expected in ours to be parallel well the
way to make sure that our apparel is
there and is providing the symbol for
you is just to import any any object
from that package in here important the
are three parallel libs we do a similar
thing from our cpp for the same reasons
let me just rebuild that convince you
that it does fix things and there we go
we've got our package built and ready to
go alright and the final little one in
your namespace is it's somewhat bizarre
that you'd have to add this since you
would think that oh my package has C++
code it has compiled code it's
the shared object the file that houses
these compiled routines is being made
generated for the package but yet I
still have to tell are explicitly oh I'm
building a library of compiled functions
and I want to use it so unfortunately
our doesn't do this automatically for
you in your namespace file you need to
make sure that you say used ein live
which it says okay I know I'm generating
I've got my package has compiled code I
want to actually use it I'm not just
compiling it for fun so if you're using
if you're building a package that has
compiled code which in this case is
using nursery parallel you'll need to
make sure that you have this used on Lib
declaration so the reason why I'm
spending time on this is just because
these are the most common stumbling
blocks when getting started with RSP
parallel once you have the template and
once you have like I I hope some of you
who are interested in using our Surrey
parallel you can just copy this package
start tweaking some of the files maybe
add some of your own and see how it
works as you play around but the last
thing I'll look at and here is these
make bars files
so here the make of ours files are the
kind of a way of setting certain
variables that affect how your package
is compiled make forests for non Windows
platforms and make bars that win for
Windows platforms so nowadays you
actually don't really need this but I'm
going to include this just because it's
nice to have it for backwards compared
with arts to be parallel but when you
build your package you basically want to
tell are that the package libs
environment variable you want to tell it
that oh yeah art should be parallel is
providing some libraries and make sure
that during compilation those are used
so in practice on non Windows machines
you don't need this nowadays but on
Windows machines you do need a make bars
dot win and that's for that's for
backwards compatibility reasons so back
in the early days of our CP parallel
when
was not supported as a platform just
because development men on Windows is
often a little more difficult than other
platforms so nowadays TBB is supported
on Windows but just to ensure that your
package works with newer versions of our
and our three parallel you need to
explicitly say this - D means define a
variable and our speed parallel use TVB
please use TVB in my package and you
attach that to your CX x legs and then
same way this is the same thing as we
saw before except a little bit more
boilerplate and constructing path to the
our script executable in this saying
make sure that use the are Surrey
parallel lives libraries when you
compile my package alright so with those
caveats which there are a few of them
but you know once you know them then you
know not to bump into them it's really
quite easy to use our speed parallel in
your own code and in your own packages
and now that you have an R package
you're ready to run our command check
once you're certain that things are
ready to go you can start sharing it
with collaborators and you put on cram
and you're good to go alright so let me
get back to my slides we're coming up to
the end so I just want to share some
materials for everyone so our three
parallel is available in crown if you
want to install it it's as simple as
installed our packages are CP parallel
if you want to use the package you can
reference this webinar and if you want
to learn more about using RC parallel
you've got a lot of resources online the
our Surrey parallel website outlines
both the high-level usages and also some
of the deeper details of using TVB
itself the our speed gallery outlines a
number of example usages of the RSB
package and the
CPV parallel package if you're curious
about what's new and are three parallel
all of our development is online on the
honor github repository and on the cran
page for our three parallel you can see
how other packages are using our SB
parallel and one kind of interesting one
that came out recently if you're working
with time series data is the role
package and that's basically for
windowed functions and behind the scenes
it's using our three parallel to do
things very fast so if you know zoo role
apply and you ever wish that could be a
little faster you may want to check that
out and so our three parallel is an
excellent tool for solving lots of these
kinds of problems alright thank you for
joining and we'll start taking some
questions so this question from sorry if
I mispronounced your name Jerry Pollock
does it work as CPU or n GPU parallel
computing this is a CPU specific
solution it's not GPU aware so the goal
here is to make the best use of your CPU
there are packages for computation on
the GPU but are sleepy parallel is
specifically targeting the processor if
you were writing code to run on other
computers is there a way to determine
the number of cores available on that
machine from within our and I believe
that's true I might not get it right on
the first try but there's see if it's in
the dot machine or dot platform now I
can't remember off the top of my head
but I know that there's routines for
that so what I would encourage you to do
for these kinds of questions is visit
the our Surrey parallel website so here
at the github that IO are to be parallel
this is where all the information about
some of the nitty-gritty stuff in RC
parallel can be answered can i define my
own ranges for splitting up data across
the workers so you can tweak the
parameters that TBB uses to divide the
data into separate ranges but
I don't think you can take the actual
level of granularity to say oh I want
this worker to specifically have well
you can tweak the grain size so you can
say oh I want say 256 or 512 bytes for
worker or maybe probably more than that
but I believe tweaking the grain size
allows you to effectively define the
size of ranges although I don't think
you could say you could customize size
different sizes for different workers
sorry the package with the rule function
it's simply called roll ro ll so that's
worth checking out if you want to see a
nice example of our three parallel used
for fast parallel computation where can
we find a good introduction to workers
and funsters for us to try to see if we
convert our our CPV code to our speed
parallel that's a great question and I
think the best place to start is the our
cpp gallery so if you saw in my um my
log and inner product examples what we
have on the r3 gallery is basically a
lot of similar things to that so we've
got a neural inner product here parallel
distant matrix computation let's take a
quick look at that so what you have here
in the arts video is these nice articles
that stand alone they present some R and
C++ code using our CVP or RS to be
parallel and this can give you very good
ideas about you know how are other
people using RC parallel and how can I
use it myself for some of the things I
want to do so from one user yes can we
paralyze a task across several computers
and the answer for this is no so the
goal of our SB parallel is to use all
the processors on one machine now you
can combine this with for example the
parallel computation packages provided
by our so you can imagine taking a
compiled routine that knows how to use
the cores all of the course on one
machine and compute that in parallel
across multiple machines so our severe
parallel takes care of the parallelism
per machine and the are parallel
libraries take care of parallels
across machines and that's the way I
would prefer to think about it
so one question RCB parable essentially
interfaces are with TVB with only two
specialized RSP parallel functions
parallel four and / / deuce that's
correct these are kind of solving the
called the embarrassingly parallel
problems in in computation but because
it bundles the TVB package everything
that TVB has is available for you so if
you're a power user and we outline a
little bit of this on the github repo
there's a whole bunch of there's a whole
bunch of tools available on TVB for
concurrent programming so once you feel
like saying okay I care enough to build
my own locks my own Cui's I I want to
take more control of how this task is
executed in parallel because the are
three parallel makes TVB available you
can just use that directly so we have
some proof documentation for kind of
diving a little bit deeper with that we
have one question how does this package
relate to using spark in our and so
these are effectively you know unrelated
spark is kind of a platform for big data
and machine learning with large data
sets provides nice you know interfaces
sequel interfaces different programming
interfaces to manipulating that data but
that lives outside of our there's you
know packages like sparkly R 4 which is
a new package introduced by R 3 or 4
interacting with spark from our studio
but the goal of ours to be parallel is
not interacting with external database
but interacting with the data you have
in memory on your machine there's one
question about how can we influence
MapReduce using our SP parallel the idea
if you want to do that that that's
basically what parallel reduce is doing
the the work information that operator
open paren close paren that's the map
function that's the transformation
you're doing on some range of data and
then the join function that's how you're
reducing or combining the results from
there
so Map Reduce is totally possible
although we don't give it the same
MapReduce name one question is it good
practice to use all but say one core and
that's kind of a tough question so the
general issue here is with parallel
computations you generally don't scale
linearly as you increase the number of
cores
unfortunately so the gain you get from
going from 1 to 4 cores might not be as
much as the gain from one from 4 to 8
cores although in this case because
we're working on so-called
embarrassingly parallel problems where
there's very little contention between
the different workers you should see
relatively high gains close to linear as
you increase the number of processors
but in general you have to tune that
yourself and our speed parallel TVB
provide API is for tuning that all right
I will take one more question the
question here is can our three parallel
be used on du or while loops or only
four and so our Surrey parallel kind of
takes the work that might be done by a
for loop and gives you a way of
expressing that in parallel and most do
or wild loops probably have a equivalent
way of expressing them with a four that
that might not be as obvious but should
be possible so in general I guess I
wouldn't think of in terms of you know I
want to convert a four loop into a
parallel four I'd say I have a range of
data I want to apply the same operation
on each element in that range of data
and I want that computation to be done
in parallel so our three parallel gives
you a mechanism for doing that alright
with that I will finish the webinar
thank everyone for joining